it's so sad to see kitten suffering and
dying in the streets that I cannot stand
it it will affect my mental health I
can't pass by kitten on the street and
not rescue it because I know it's going
to have a horrible life until it dies
holyland cats that walked in the
footsteps at the kings and prophets of
Israel it's a bit of a surprise for
everyone who comes here you know that
first they'll see one cat and they'll
say oh look a cat and then they start
seeing a whole lot more cats like not a
normal number and until people realize
that there are a huge number of stray
cats not just in Israel but the entire
Mediterranean basin where it's warm
weather and the winters are very mild
[Music]
I never leave the house without a large
bag of cat food in my pack I make a
certain sound to call them for food so
they associate the sound that I make and
me with food and they come running and
they recognize me when I call them I try
to keep a very low profile a lot of my
neighbors really don't get animals at
all the attitude in Jerusalem towards
stray cats in general I would say that
the non-religious Western Jews are the
most involved in animal welfare issues
and I'm a religious Jew I became
religious as an adult and I have
tremendous respect for each group but
the more religious the group is it turns
out that they have the least experience
with animals and that tends to be a fear
of them so they're not involved with
them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
let me pet you what is it there I have
ran into some people in the middle of
the night
like in the Muslim quarters and the
Christian quarters
you know resident Arabs in the old city
and some of them are curious they asked
me what I'm doing and I explained it to
them and you see the wheels turning in
their head and they start to smile and
they nod their head and then they said
good for you I work on the head at ala
Sufi
my home is a revolving door I can't pass
up any kitten on the street because I
know it's just having a horrible
horrible time and they all come from
different places different stories
you're delicious this is grace grace was
almost dead when I found her in the
Christian quarter very close to the
Church of the Holy Sepulchre yeah hi
Nora
Noor is the sweetest she has a
neurological problem that's permanent
when she was a tiny kitten something hit
her in the head I don't know what but
that's what the doctor said she still
falls over a lot but she's a very happy
cat the classic problem is that there's
a lot of people who are putting out a
lot of food for a lot of cats but
they're not spaying them so they wander
off they get hurt they starve they get
they die of disease there's only a limit
to the amount of food available for
these street cuts you know people think
oh they'll manage there's plenty of
garbage well there isn't you know if you
check any garbage can more often than
not there's nothing for a cat to eat in
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but no we try to do the best bit for
them here overcrowding is very very
unhealthy physically and emotionally for
cats very stressful but if there's one
message I think I could give to people
is some spay and neuter your cats spay
and neuter cats in the street since the
year 2009 when I started keeping count
I've been prowling the streets of the
old city laid it like slepping big traps
it's just an enormous amount of work it
sort of means like being always on call
like you could just get cozy in bed and
just want to unplug and the phone ring
and it will be someone saying that
there's a sick cat in the Muslim Quarter
come and get it you know and all it
takes is a few cats to reverse all the
work that you've done a few cuts having
kittens and then then having kittens
[Music]
there was a rabbi who lived about a
hundred years ago in Germany named rabbi
Samson Raphael Hirsch and he said that
it's not enough to not cause pain to
animals that if you see an animal
suffering even it's not your own and
even if you didn't cause a suffering
it's up to you to do something to rescue
it
[Music]